you're gonna be live a very safe life
the only problem is the monster is you
touch like you're saying the terror is
you like the monster is you in this
movie so how are you your own worst
enemy well I'll tell you whenever I
start a film I am my worst enemy for
sure and this film was no different
in fact this film for a second that I I
really thought I might I really was
worried for myself that I would give up
and buckle and just be like Jordan I
think you need to find another actor cuz
I just don't think I have what it takes
because I was playing not one but two
characters in the same movie and I was
panicked because usually I had the time
it takes to prepare for one film and my
critic in my head oh she is she is
powerful and she knows how to to freak
me out and it took having people I love
around me who could remind me of the
things I wasn't in that only moment able
to see for myself to build that
confidence you know to say I know I
could you know I know I can do this
because the thing about acting like in
this movie I've never done this before
yeah you know I'm a true beginner and
here's Jordan such an intelligent man
what an amazing start to his direct
directing career everybody is looking to
see what he's gonna do next
he he can he knows BS when he sees it
you know and so and I'm starting knowing
less than knowing more and of course and
I have patience with myself to get there
they look exactly like us
is it true that you saw get out five
times in nine months
yeah between the in by Panther to the m8
that makes you know like Jordan is where
who I want to work with well yeah I mean
he was someone I admired from key and
Peele you know sometimes I played this
bucket lace this game in my head I'm
like who have all the actors out there
what do I want to work with and I like
yeah yeah yeah and he was definitely one
of them and then I found it he was
director and I saw get out and I was
like okay this is incredible this man is
like no other he's saying you know he
has he is singular and he's so talented
so funny so cool to work with him and it
was just another thought in my head of
like one day one day this is gonna
happen and then a few months later he's
like here is a script and you get to
work with me twice and I'm like since
you were so freaked out that you were
paired back up with Winston and was so
soothing because you know this was a big
step for me this is the first time I'm
playing an honest-to-god real lead
character in the film and yeah two leads
at that and so to have Winston as my
scene partner was such a comfort because
we have we went to the same school we
speak the same dramatic language because
of that we had black panther behind us
and we have a friendship we have an
intimacy that you know is unbreakable
and so I could I could trust him and go
to dangerous places and I knew that he
was there to you really support and my
process and I could support his
you